aquí tenemos dos piezas importantes para
resolver nuestro problema primero nos
dicen que 11 es igual a 8 más la función
inversa de x menos 3 y por otra parte
tengo que f de 3 es igual a 10 lo que
quiero que hagas justo ahorita es que
pausa es el vídeo e intentes encontrar
el valor de x
y bueno tal vez en un principio esto
suene bastante llamativo tener una
función inversa por aquí sin embargo lo
primero que yo haría es intentar
simplificar lo más que se pueda esta
información así que en esta ecuación que
tengo aquí donde está involucrada la
función inversa lo que se me ocurre
primero es restar 8 de ambos lados de
esta igualdad de tal manera que aquí voy
a restar 8 y de este lado también voy a
restar 8 para que solamente quede de un
lado la función inversa y entonces que
me va a quedar
bueno pues de este lado me queda 11
menos 8 lo cual es 3 ok y del otro lado
me va a quedar que estos dos se van y
solamente me queda la función inversa de
x menos 3 así que le voy a poner aquí la
función inversa de x menos 3 del lujo y
es más lo puedo escribir también por
aquí
al menos 1 de x 3 de x menos 3
esto es exactamente igual que 3 porque
al final aquí tenemos dos piezas muy
importantes de información que nos van a
ayudar a resolver el problema después de
que simplificamos justo por aquí y es
que por aquí hay algo bastante
interesante fíjate en un principio dice
efe de 3 esto es igual las 10 y por otra
parte me dice que la función inversa de
x menos 3 esto es lo mismo que 3 aquí
hay algo bastante interesante y es que
basta recordar que significa tomarnos la
función inversa si por ejemplo aquí
tuviera vamos a dibujar por acá aquí
tengo el dominio de esta función
un niño de esta función y por acá por
acá y maxim ante que tengo el dominio de
esta función y lo voy a poner aquí el
dominio todo me dio ok y lo que nosotros
sabemos es que la función mapea el 3 al
10 si nosotros tenemos por aquí al 3 al
3 lo mapea al valor de 10 esto en la
función eso quiere decir que entonces la
función inversa mapea del -10 al 3 esto
en la función inversa la función inversa
mapea al 10 al valor de 3 por lo tanto
efe inversa del 10 es lo mismo que 3 y
dejan apuntarlo aquí
efe inversa ok de 10 esto es exactamente
igual que 3 por lo tanto esta igualdad
no está diciendo lo mismo que esta
igualdad o dicho de otra manera
x menos 3
x 3 tiene que ser lo mismo que 10 x 3
tiene que ser lo mismo que 10 y si ahora
sumamos 3 de ambos lados voy a obtener
que x es lo mismo que 13 y ya está aquí
tenemos por fin el valor de x